like most popular shows these days HBO's
Westworld is chock-full of extra goodies
for eagle-eyed viewers we've rounded up
the biggest Westworld
Easter eggs that you might not have
noticed on the series so far oh and just
so you know partner there are spoilers
ahead by Oh shocking West world's
married creators Lisa joy and Jonathan
Nolan hadn't been shy about the
inspiration video games that provided to
the show in addition to franchises like
Grand Theft Auto and Red Dead Redemption
the Bioshock games and their incredible
attention to detail have also been a
major influence on Nolan and Joy's
series that's probably why the third
episode of West world features a
familiar face to Bioshock fans well a
familiar head to be specific that sure
seems like the head of Sandra Cohen a
prominent resident of Bioshock city of
Rapture just hanging out on set dress
for success after the first few episodes
a lot of fans started comparing West's
world to Alice in Wonderland
since both deal with a hidden fantasy
world where nothing is quite what it
seems
remember not only that but the Alice in
Wonderland story has a part to play in
the show as well in episode 3 Bernard
asks Dolores to read passages from
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland so can
it be much of a coincidence that Dolores
looks kinda like most modern depictions
of Alice with her blonde hair and blue
dress from Alice to Abraham's reddit
user red widow spotted another Alice
related reference in episode 3
Bernard asks Dolores to read this
passage your dear how queer everything
is today and yesterday things went on
just as usual I wonder if I've been
changed in the night that quote is also
a throwback to another flagship
production from executive producer JJ
Abrams lost in episode 10 of season 4
Jack reads the same passage to Claire's
son Aaron as a bedtime story
dear dear how queer everything is today
and yesterday things went on just as
usual I wonder if I've been changed in
the night play it again Sam West world
doesn't just take its cues from
Victorian era literature and spaghetti
westerns it's also got a modern-day
soundtrack kind of take a listen to the
piano in the mariposa saloon episode one
had Soundgarden's black hole son
episode two had Radiohead's no surprises
an episode four featured a forest by the
cure
so why fill the futuristic Wild West
simulation with hits from college radio
Jonathan Nolan explained at New York
comic-con in 2016 it's to remind you
that this isn't a Western that this
isn't taking place in the nineteenth
century it's taking place somewhere else
some time else Delos if you didn't know
the premise of Westworld comes from a
1973 science fiction movie written and
directed by novelist Michael Crichton
the same guy who wrote that book about
the other theme park featuring exciting
and dangerous attractions Jurassic Park
mine is about a futuristic amusement
park where dinosaurs are brought to life
through advanced cloning techniques I
call it Billy and the clone asuras oh
you have looked beginning so anyway the
original movies version of Westworld is
actually one part of a theme park called
Delos in the show Delos is back though
in a slightly different form this time
around Westfield seems to be a park in
and of itself that's run by a
corporation called Delos Incorporated
you see their logo pop up occasionally
on the show like when Bernard and Stubbs
go down to the cold storage level in
Episode one in that scene you can see a
globe with the word Delos featured
prominently in the center and that isn't
the only call back to the movie that the
show's worked in the gunslinger in
episode 6 Bernard takes the elevator way
down to level B 82 to check up on
anomalies in the park while he's down
there swinging his flashlight around the
dark sublevel the light Falls for an
instant on a shadowy cowboy pushed back
up against the wall recognized anything
that old cowboy in the background is
none other than an exact pose perfect
match of yul brenner in character as the
murderous gunslinger in the west-world
film from 1973 jurassic bird so we know
that the new West World references the
Old West world and more than just name
in concept but Michael Crichton's
Jurassic Park gets a little nod - did
you miss it in episode 5 we see Felix
the technician taking a stab at
programming with a little sparrow just
as he's getting started Felix leans down
to the table to coax the bird along
where have we heard that before
come on come on come on pretty cool
connection of course there's really only
one line from Jurassic Park that just
has to find its way into West world
before the series ends you know the one
will go on to you but thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to